and the real story of block was I went
home that afternoon I was like I'm
launching a consulting firm to help
companies figure out ethereum hours
after learning about ethereum
[Music]
um all right we're live this is it this
is how we start Ben we get in you just
rip into it huh we get right into it
where are you calling from your place
looks nice is this your apartment yeah
yeah this is the blockworks office yeah
we got a new office like about a year
ago in Manhattan how many um how many
people do you have like 60 uh I think
we're up to 65 maybe we had six people
start this week so I think I think that
might put us at 65. what's the pitch for
what you are you're just uh I mean at
the high level a crypto media company
but what did I tell you the other day I
go you do everything right you do things
the right way wait let me just get this
straight so is Sean not joining us
because do you know that Sean told John
dm'd me one day he gave me his cell
phone he said dude hit me up would love
to meet and chat I've never met the guy
I he he gives me a cell phone I text him
I go yo it's Jason it's what's up man I
said something about friend Tech Guy
ghosted me never just left me on red
really this was gonna be my time on air
to call out Sean but alas well you
called him out no Sean's out Sean's
getting a nose job he's out with surgery
this week really yeah but but he'll
he'll hear this
all right Sean's a ghoster man Sean is a
ghost or I give him a heart for I give
him a hard time for that but you know he
brings the heat so he he gets a pass so
what are we talking today I don't know
man tell people like you're under the
radar but your business is shockingly
big and I think it's going to be
incredibly successful what do you what's
like the pitch for what blockworks is
block work started six years ago so my
co-founder Mike and I started it in
December of 2017. basically the thesis
back then which Remains the Same I think
we've got a lot wrong over the years but
one thing we got really right was the
thesis uh which was that crypto as an
asset class and as an industry is going
to grow exponentially over the coming
years and this was back in 2017 when
most of the information about the asset
class was basically like siled on Reddit
and Twitter and our thesis was that as
the industry grew exponentially those
investors who and professionals who came
into the industry they weren't gonna you
know listen to
crypto Panda or like crypto whale about
this new asset class they wanted this
professional source of information kind
of like a Bloomberg or Wall Street
Journal for crypto so yeah we said hey
let's go build it and that was six years
ago so what we've built is basically for
the first five years we've built a media
media platform Media company right we
own the largest Network podcasts in the
industry we have a couple big
newsletters we have uh I think the best
team of reporters uh and you know
journalists in the industry we own a
couple of the large conferences in the
industry and we've built this big media
company and a year ago we thought the
industry was ready for like deeper what
I call almost like bottom of the funnel
information about crypto data analytics
research protocol governance and that is
our subscription platform that we
launched called blockworks research so
that was a year ago so that's what yeah
we're a median information platform just
about crypto crypto native media and
information company do you say how big
you are did you see the research my guy
so I have Eugenio he's my uh yeah he
like had your revenue and ebitda was
that all right correct yeah it's crazy I
like he's doing like he's that guy's
digging he said the 2023 you're going to
do 25 million in Revenue with 8 million
in ebitda he says 2022 you did 25 and 7
million in ebitda is that right I'm not
going to say specific numbers but what I
will say is yeah last year we had a goal
of uh 20 million in revenue and we
pretty decently exceeded that
um and we've been profitable since day
one so yeah we bootstrapped the business
for the first five and a half years and
then back in April or May we took uh we
raised our first outside round of
capital from from 10t and framework and
uh this Angel Santiago so we raised 12
million bucks out of 135 valuation
um
and yeah we've been profitable since
then I mean kind of since we started we
did a decent bit of Evita last year this
year uh those numbers are wrong because
this year just to kind of share a little
bit of insights into like the crypto
Market I don't know how I think you
followed pretty closely Sam the Market's
just gotten crushed right so what's
actually done really well for us this
year is our subscription revenue on the
research platform but the ad market
across the board both in crypto and
digital media if you probably talked to
the morning Brew guys or you probably
saw the BuzzFeed numbers because they're
public like
it's got It's it's uh it's been a
tougher year than last year on the ad
Market
is it coming back now
it's the ad Market is just starting to
come back yeah but you guys crush it on
conferences I mean I went to your
conference what did you have 5 000
people there the conference the final
number was a little above 4 000 this
year yeah I mean that was amazing you it
seems like you filled it there
um yeah I mean I think that like I'm a
media nerd I I think that everyone who
has a media business ever works in the
media business they hate it and they
love it uh I hate it but it's like an
art that I'm addicted to
um I hate selling ads but I love
creating media and when I look at you
know media is an interesting business
because the barrier to entry is really
low
particularly for the written word well
even for podcasts everyone can write
therefore everyone the the pool of
people who think they're good writers is
significantly higher than like building
some other type of business
um and I think that most people do it
really poorly myself included I made a
lot of mistakes but whenever like you're
telling me about your guys's business
I'm like oh I see a well from an outside
I see a crystal clear path to like 100
million in sales
um you just do the same [__] but more
and more and you just are thoughtful man
you do things right and I I think that
you're one of the more under the radar
operators in the space thanks man that's
why I think a digital media business is
actually one of the best businesses to
start it's not going to make you a
billionaire there's no like go start you
had the you had the the the flying guy
on the podcast the other day like that's
what you'd go through if you want to be
a billionaire like a digital media brand
I think is like the best Venture into
entrepreneurship for first-time Founders
and Mike and I like Mike and I were just
roommates at the time and we were 23
when we launched the business we
basically just worked we would wake up
at like 4 a.m we'd jump on LinkedIn we
had no media business we didn't even
know what media was we just we just
wanted to host an event because we went
to an event realized they made like 5
000 bucks that was big money to us and
so we just jumped on LinkedIn every
morning we would wake up and just send
like 300 messages right 10 of those
people reply that's 30. you get like
three out of the 30 to actually buy a
ticket our first event February 2018 we
had 220 people and we made Top Line 12
000 bucks I think it was and so that's
that's Off to the Races and then we
ended up building the a media company
basically asked backwards right like how
you probably started with the hustle was
with content yeah you you did it
horribly horribly horribly horrible I
would argue though like the problem with
most media companies and the reason they
don't work is because they're started by
folks who can't monetize so they're
usually started by a podcast host or a
newsletter writer in 2023 and they're
brilliant content and they don't
understand how to sell so what happens
is they're a year and a half in they're
like oh [__] I need to monetize and they
don't know how to build a business they
know how to create great content and for
us we did events then we linked up with
pomp right and we that we got into the
podcasting game so our first podcast was
pumps well it used to be called off the
chain now it's called the pom podcast
but you're just selling ads for him
right we were doing everything I would
go into Palms office seven days a week
Saturdays and Sundays too I would put
the mic in front of his face I learned
how to use GarageBand I was editing the
podcast I was producing the podcast we
were designing the things on 99 designs
I was selling the sponsorships we were
doing all of it
um and then we built that business out
and hosted shows for other people
realized that business was great for
Avenue sucked for IP because we don't
actually own the content yeah you're
just an agency yeah then covet hit and
80 of our Revenue got wiped out
overnight because we were 80 of Revenue
came from events and then that's when we
pivoted into like we said let's go do
the media thing how much could you say
how many how many uh how much in sales
you're you're like one event would do
um yeah our biggest one I mean last year
we did like well over 10 million from
permissionless
dude that's insane man my whole thing
with events was I started with hustle
cone
hustlecon so I did it the same thing as
you where like I threw it together and
hosted it in six weeks I think the first
time I did it I think I did 50 000 in
revenue and like 20 000 in profit the
second time I did it I think it did a
hundred and sixty thousand in Revenue
and 50 000 in profit maybe and then the
third and fourth time it varied between
like 500 000 and a million I think in
sales
and then I don't remember what the
profit was but the margins got smaller
and events were hard I was like I know
these events can get big but I screwed
it up because what I did was I made the
event about I just like looked at like I
had never been to conferences I just
looked at what a TED Talk was and I was
like I'm just gonna do that I'm just
gonna get people on a stage
and people are gonna sit in the audience
and like listen to this
that was really dumb for from a money
making point of view that was a really
stupid thing to do and I knew that some
of these events were doing like tens of
millions in sales and I totally screwed
it up the the way that you really make
revenue and income through these events
is the speakers are simply
a way to get the similar like-minded
people in the in the audience and you
make money through more expensive ticket
sales because you're doing networking
and you make money not through
sponsorships people call them
sponsorships but like through like a
booth so they could actually it like
it's basically just a Marketplace that
day where like you have to make people
are making deals conferences are
basically just uh three-day marketplaces
where you build the marketplace and you
shut it down three days later and that's
what the show floor is Sheldon Adelson
so there's this guy named Sheldon I
think his name's Sheldon Adelson Ximena
just died he started this thing called
uh Comm decks I think it was and it was
eventually turned into CES I think it
like uh rebranded but anyway he created
this conference called comdex and it was
like the computer show or something a
computer it was right when computers
were getting popular in the 70s 80s and
90s he built it up he actually sold it
for a billion dollars but Sheldon
adelson's the guy who basically made the
Vegas Strip like it made it happening
because what he noticed was he goes oh
wow this conference I'm basically just
creating like a it's basically a real
estate business because I'm creating a
Marketplace and I'm like a merchant in
the sense of like I'm selling like
Corner space because that's the best
space that I'm selling this space and
like Marketplace it's a Marketplace for
those few days and then he's like well
[__] I'm just going to get into real
estate industry because he saw like
loads of different parallels and uh
anyway when I like read that I was
already like pretty deep into like my
one big event and I was like [__] I did
this all wrong you know what I mean I
don't even think you did it wrong you
just needed to go bigger so the secret
with events so we started with small
events the thing that a lot of
entrepreneurs get wrong with events is
the business model of small events is a
is a really good experience for
attendees it's really fun you bring
people together good community building
it is a [__] business model so the kind
of secret to events is you need to
figure out how to go really big and go
bigger and bigger and bigger and what we
found out some early insights was let's
say you have a company
like uh like coinbase right and coinbase
might pass a million dollars to sponsor
our conference if we launched another
conference they're not going to go past
2 million they're going to take that
million that they allocate to their
blockworks conference budget and they're
going to cut it in half so then they're
spending 500 with us here and 500 with
us here so but we're doing twice the
work right to go run two conferences so
we basically Consolidated all of our
things we now just have two conferences
digital asset Summit and permissionless
and the reason for that is like that is
the best
business model for conferences is bigger
is better what's really tough is
um big conferences you have to plan out
years in advance so our events team
would like us to book venues like four
or five years out
we can't do that because crypto's too
cyclical so we but we still have to like
I think we just booked our 2026 venue or
or we're like about we have we have the
contract for them so and why that's
really tough for our business is because
crypto is so cyclical and if you think
you're planning a big event
but you don't end up having you're not
able to host the big event you can crush
your business right coindesk almost died
in 2019 because of that reason
um they had like I don't know 10 000
plus people in 2018 and then in 2019
they fell to like 2 000 people right
they fell eighty percent and that almost
wiped out their whole business and their
takeaway from that was
hey maybe events big events aren't going
to come back big events aren't going to
be big like crypto events just aren't
going to be big again and what happened
is you end up losing money on the upside
when the when the market comes back you
lose money on the upside so for us like
it's just a big challenge to running a
conference business in such a cyclical
industry is you have to plan these
things years in advance but then you're
basically asking yourself to like
predict Market Cycles very tough thing
to do but you're big enough now that
like you said that like cities are like
courting you right yeah so these the
bigger your conference gets the more GDP
you bring into a city so I forget the I
forget the specific number but I think
for Palm Beach last year we brought in
like
I don't know three or four or five or
six million dollars of GDP to Palm Beach
just in those three days so they so
they're the mayor of Palm Beach came to
our conference he really wanted us to
come back
um
and the bigger your conference gets the
more cities and then even countries will
Court like countries will Court like web
Summit and money 2020 and folks like
that and they'll give them big upfronts
how much do you think that up front was
for a web Summit web Summit has what 50
000 people yeah a couple couple million
probably I don't know five five million
maybe 10 maybe some money in tax credits
that's insane man I um yeah yeah I mean
like I I haven't cracked the code for an
event but you have that's why that's why
I like hanging out with you but like
it's freaking stressful it is stressful
that's one of the reasons why I hate
events yeah 50 of tickets get sold in
the four in the four weeks leading up to
a conference so imagine the fifth week
out from a conference you're basically
thinking that 50 of your attendees
aren't coming and you know it because
there's six years of data that they're
gonna come but it's stressful but
ultimately the conference serves as like
it's the reason we were able to
bootstrap the business right it serves
as like the cash flow into the
podcasts and into the research business
and into the digital and news and all
that stuff and uh another thing that I
like about hanging out with you so like
basically for The Listener I uh I spend
my summers in Brooklyn one year Jason
was like hey there's this uh apartment
in my building that's available you want
to rent it out and I was like hell yeah
so I lived three floors below you for
about four months hung out with you a
bunch and an interesting thing about you
is you're one of the better storytellers
I've ever hung out with Sean Sean Perry
partner Sean awesome it's awesome at
telling stories you've you've told some
of the craziest stories I've ever heard
of particularly one about when you like
won a did you win a Corvette oh man so I
was super I was nervous for this podcast
not because I'm nervous to go on
podcasts but uh I was telling Dana last
night I was like I'm actually pretty
nervous for this podcast Sam knows too
much about me to to make this I'll give
you I'll give you I'll give you a pass
on anything anything you don't want to
talk about you know and I asked you
ahead of time I said what don't you want
to talk about I'll share anyone I think
Sean and I joke we're like
if you were like really good at gaming
if you were like good at poker if you
like were a hacker if you did like most
people not most but a lot of people who
end up with like huge amounts of
financial success they were doing
something like gray early in their
career before they realized like oh I
actually like follow the book and like
do things by the rules because that is
way better for long-term success but
they had that like Gene in them a
hundred percent you told this story and
when I heard that story I was like oh
yeah like it would have been obvious at
the age of 16 or 18 that you were gonna
be like a massive success when you told
me this story it was one of the crazier
things I've ever heard of I'll tell I'll
tell an abbreviated version because I
don't I don't think it's as interesting
as you do but I've always had this
company don't don't give me the
abbreviated version I've always had this
entrepreneurial tick like I um my
parents shared this story with me the
other day I guess when I was in like
fourth or fifth or sixth grade or
something I would buy this is not the
story I'll get to the story but I would
buy uh MLB Showdown cards on eBay that I
thought they were marketing it poorly
and like maybe the picture was bad or
the description was bad I'd buy the MLB
Showdown cards I'd take a nicer picture
with a nice camera re-upload the exact
same card to eBay with just a better
picture and better marketing copy and
sell it for like 2x what we bought what
I bought it for so I've always had that
kind of Bend this um has pulled me down
good rabbit holes like that or like
block works and then some less good
rabbit holes which I think is the story
you're getting to
um somewhere after
senior year of high school I summer
after senior year of high school I
wanted some money some summer money so I
went to my parents was like hey can I
get some money I'm in high school I
don't have a job let me get some money
they're like you're not you're not
getting money we're not giving you money
uh go my remember my mom said I think
your friend Jake is getting a job at
Taco Bell go work with Jake at Taco Bell
I said I'm not going to Taco Bell and we
we would go to Taco Bell every day I
love Taco Bell and um so I was like I'm
not going to I'm not working at Taco
Bell so my buddy was a year above me in
school and he would he uh he went to
school at the University of Hawaii and
he was back from his freshman year of
college he's like hey I heard about this
thing where it was actually the Soylent
podcast guy uh or the Soylent Guy
brought it up on his on your podcast
with him it's he's like most companies
spend like 40 of their budget on
marketing
these there are another type of company
that spends zero on marketing 40 on
Affiliates who Market their products for
them and that was kind of the pitch that
my buddy gave me he's like if you are
able to sell this energy drink to other
people you can make money you get like a
percentage of what they make and again
I'm 18. I didn't know anything I just
wanted money and I didn't want to work
at Taco Bell so I
signed up I bought like 30 energy drinks
and started telling people that like hey
you drink Red Bull and Monster you
should you shouldn't do that you should
buy these healthy energy drinks from me
go you go to like you know it's dot you
know the web the website.com and uh
anyways I I did it for a couple months
didn't make any money I get to college I
went to Emory down in Atlanta and I
really didn't want to be like
the energy drink guy you know I'm trying
to be like cool on campus freshmen
didn't want didn't want to be like the
energy drink guy and uh I talked to some
friends they didn't want to do it but
then I discovered like digital marketing
and actually like Noah Kagan and like
all those people like that whole crowd
they were kind of booming back in the
day like they were just kind of finding
some success and found that whole crowd
of like that guy Branson something or
Russell Brunson yeah figured out how to
create landing pages
um went super deep down that rabbit hole
and the business got crazy so you got
paid like a percentage this is where I
didn't realize what I was doing looking
back there's a lot of like I'm not sure
if I would do this well I probably
wouldn't do this again I actually think
about like what I let my kid do this
um in the future but yeah ended up
having 4 600 people and my downline had
like a thousand people in France
um you know because it was it was a it
wasn't that you were making money just
selling this drink you're making money
from enlisting people to sell it for you
so basically it was a pyramid scheme
multi-level marketing yeah you told the
story you're like you I told my parents
what I was doing and they're like Jason
you know this is a a multi-level
marketing you're like what do you mean
I'm just selling a drink like you didn't
even know what that meant right I so
this company was the Like official
sponsor of the Phoenix Suns The Dr Oz
was on my if any of my friends from
college are listening to us they're
going to laugh at this because they have
heard this pitch probably a thousand
times I used to like get on Skype it
wasn't Zoom back then it was Skype and
I'd give this pitch to like a room of
500 people like Dr Oz says that you know
a can of can of this and a handful of
almonds is the healthiest thing that you
can put in your body blah blah so they
had all these big names I had no idea I
really fell for the pitch that it was
like look a lot of companies like a Nike
spends billions on marketing why don't
they just spend billions giving it to
when Sam tells me about Nike they should
give Sam like 10 of that 10 of that what
I didn't realize was there's all these
companies there's this multi-level
Market I didn't realize that there's
this whole industry three and it wasn't
until
well to to bring this story home and the
car wasn't a Corvette as a BMW I got so
high up in this company or had so many
people below me the company gave me a
BMW
uh my sophomore year of college I I
tried dropping out my sophomore year got
like a 2.2 or 2.4 GPA my obviously my
parents wouldn't let me they knew they
they were like
I later learned that it was a big debate
my parents had about whether or not to
let me keep doing this my mom wanted to
shut it down from day one and my dad was
like it'll teach him a good lesson I
don't think they really I don't think
they thought I was gonna be successful
but it wasn't until uh Bill Ackerman and
Carl Icahn got into that really crazy
battle over Herbalife and I watched the
full thing I watched the whole
presentation by Bill Ackman that I
realized I was like oh my God he is
explaining this company that work that
I'm working with and uh and then my and
then my roommate junior year like one of
my best friends like basically slapped
me in the face junior year he's like all
right man we're gonna get internships
you should join us uh stop doing this
stop doing this thing and and wish and
it shut down so what is it how much
money do you make if you have 4 000
people on your like downline or whatever
it's called I was making probably a
thousand fifteen hundred bucks a week as
a sophomore but that's four thousand
people so shitload of people I would
have thought you'd make way more there
were people making millions a year who
had like if there I probably had four
thousand on one side like 600 on the
other if my sides were like even then um
then it would I guess they probably did
some model internally that has like made
the company more sustainable if it was
like even so
yeah that's so that's what it was but I
was I mean for I was 19 right I was a
year and a half after wanting to work at
Taco Bell or not wanting to work at Taco
Bell so like that was crazy crazy money
for me
and you're just like giving speeches in
front of hundreds of people on Skype
about why this drink is is awesome or
why the business is awesome basically
the pit yeah kind of both like the so
the difference between so you brought up
pyramid scheme the like technical
difference as The Regulators see it
between a multi-level marketing company
which is I would call very shady but
technically legal versus a pyramid
scheme which is illegal is the
percentage of people who buy the product
for the product itself versus the number
of people the percentage of people who
buy the product just to get access to be
able to sell it and make more money so
that's the like the reason something
like Amway or like Herbalife can be
still exist is because there's actually
a pretty high percentage of people who
just buy the products because they like
the products like Cutco knives and all
those so yeah is a multi-level Market I
mean I've got a ton of friends that sold
cut code knives and you know what's
crazy they all say awesome stuff about
the product so like an MLM isn't
inherently or nothing right I think like
it wasn't like Tupperware like uh this
company had been around for 10 years
that was the other thing it had been
around for like 10 or 11 or 12 years and
they sold to like 50 and 60 year olds
who wanted to get like protein shakes
and all that stuff and it was a really
good product and nobody did the money
part of it they just got it and they
might tell some friends but like most
people who use Amway products they don't
tell their friends about it they just
actually like the products so that was
this company and then they realized hey
who wants money more than anyone like 19
year old kids so they launched and what
do 19 year old kids drink they drink
energy drinks so that's when they
launched that they did flashy marketing
they sponsored the Suns they got Dr Oz
as a spokesperson all this stuff and
that's when it really that's when the
percentage of people buying the product
for the
to make money started to outweigh the
number of people buying the product for
the for the drink how big was that
company I don't know I don't I don't
have metrics the CEO I think went to
jail for a year or two though oh my god
well it happens
one of the things like I actually I
wasn't even sure I wanted to talk about
it on the podcast today because I have a
lot of
not regret but like it is inherently
kind of a shady thing to talk about
right it's like multi-level marketing is
a shady thing and I didn't realize it at
the time I truly I truly had no idea I'd
like drank the Kool-Aid so hard I really
had no idea
and the debate I have I don't have any
kids but if I had a kid would I let my
kid do this and the immediate answer is
no like that it is super Shady no but
it did teach I I know for a fact I would
not be here today if I hadn't done that
why is that
block work started by just me posting on
LinkedIn a lot about crypto and nobody
was posting on social nobody was posting
on LinkedIn back then like it gave me
the confidence to post on social a lot
it gave me the like understanding that
Mo does like most of growing a business
at the beginning is just like grit and
hustle and really marketing and sales
it's less product eventually that
changes over time as you find product
Market fit and all that kind of stuff
um
and it just taught me this like it it
made me realize that I there was nothing
in the world I wanted to do outside of
build a company and it gave me the I
like I didn't I didn't know how to build
a software company like you have some
like Geniuses come on the show like
they're coders like I wasn't like that
um and it just gave me the confidence to
go do it so were you thinking about any
other different ideas before you started
block works
um yeah I was desperate for something I
was really desperate for to do something
but I had a bunch of [__] ideas
um
I the way blockworks originally started
who's the consultant that you had on the
show ovens same ovens so the way block
work started Sam Evans plays a role I
wanted to start a Consulting practice
because I saw I read Sam evans's stuff
and I like I didn't buy his course but I
saw all of his ads and I was like this
dude's making it it was funny hearing
that like New York photo shoot that he
did you know what I'm talking about I
like remember seeing that ad I was like
obviously now I know how the game works
that wasn't a real thing but
he I I wanted to like do what Sam Evans
did start a consulting firm by the way
Sam Evans is this guy who came on our
pod nowadays he's like a really nerdy
like almost like an intellectual he
started a software company and he's
doing everything right but previously he
started this thing called consulting.com
he rented out this slick apartment slick
back his hair wore a bright blue blazer
and I don't think he did anything
unethical but he was um like selling the
dream he was like I started a Consulting
business that makes money I'm gonna
teach you how to do that too for this
amount of money and he came on our pod
and he was like
I don't remember exactly what he said
but I think the energy that I got from
him was he's like I don't regret doing
that because I helped a lot of people
but I was playing a part that wasn't
authentic to me and I got bummed out
maybe there was a little like regret
he's like I've [__] played a part
like I was an actor and I don't think he
regrets it because I don't think he did
anything wrong but he just pushed it to
the to the Limit yeah so I saw those ads
that's what I wanted to do I was like
really sick of my job I wanted to do
that and so I so I used to go to this
thing called brunchwork or something in
New York I don't think they exist
anymore but I would go to all these
events they had a thing on how to build
a consulting firm at
2PM on a Sunday I think it was like 2
p.m on a Sunday they had a thing how to
build a consulting firm I thought it was
you just gets sucked into these like
scabs
one day if you ever talk to Mike I'll
tell you about the uh the Jerry Seinfeld
ticket ticket flipping scheme did not
make money
um anyways we uh I get there an hour
early because I thought it was at 1pm
and they were doing a talk on ethereum
and I already knew about Bitcoin from
since 2015 I was living in Budapest
heard about Bitcoin 2017 this is 2017
now uh got really into ethereum from
this talk and so I decided I went I came
home that day and the real story of
block was I went home that afternoon I
was like I'm launching a consulting firm
to help companies figure out ethereum
hours after learning about ethereum
hours after I was like sold the dream
yeah
um I was like this is what I've been
looking for well I I you know I've known
about Bitcoin for two years I was
already like listening to bitcoin
podcasts and stuff and like kind of had
heard about ethereum but like didn't
unders didn't click didn't get it and uh
came home and I was living with four
guys at the time and one of them was
Mike who's my co-founder and I were we
remember it slightly differently what I
remember is him saying let's do it and
then waking up in the morning and saying
hey this is a horrible idea I currently
work in Consulting nobody's going to buy
Consulting from us because they don't
trust us when we're 23 years old we need
to build trust with the community how do
we do that and I said great how do we do
that he said what if we hosted events we
went to that event last month that made
some money so we started hosting events
to then try to sell Consulting and six
years later we have no Consulting but
hey guys really quick so you may know
this but my beginning in business was
being a copywriter I'm a self-top
copywriter and what that means is I
figured out what motivated people and
then I figured out how to use the
written word to get them to do what I
want them to do so that could mean
selling them a product that could mean
writing a speech or even giving a speech
and giving someone to buy into a
particular movement it could be
recruiting hell you could do it for
dating it just basically means figuring
out what motivates someone and how to
use the written word to take an action
get them to take an action or to think a
certain way and the way that I learned
how to copyright was I did this thing
called copywork and copywork is this
famous technique that's not really
popular anymore but it used to be really
really popular and you basically take
writing that is great writing that you
love and you write it out by hand and
you copy it and you make notes of what
particular thing that that writer is
doing that makes it special this is the
exact same way that you learn how to
play the piano when you want to learn
how to play the piano you learn how to
play Happy Birthday and then you learn
how to play like Jingle Bells and then
maybe like a rock and roll song and then
maybe like a hip-hop song and eventually
you can combine that all together after
a few years and you learn how to make
music that's your own same thing with
writing that's how I learned how to
write I locked myself in a room for six
months and I just did this for many
hours a day uh I created a program to
make it easy so you could do that it's
called copy that copy that.com you can
go there and you can check it out it's a
10-day exercise to make it really easy
to learn how to write if you want you
can just go do this on your own you can
find great writing you just literally
copy it by hand I know it sounds crazy
but it works really effectively but I
made something that makes it a little
bit easier so check it out copy that dot
com and we will talk soon and back to
the pod
[Music]
where's the worst have you heard of
HubSpot see most crms are a cobble
together mess but HubSpot is easy to
adopt and actually looks gorgeous I
think I love our new CRM our software is
the best HubSpot grow better
dude it's so funny I think that like all
right so blackworks is gonna be a huge
success I don't know what how big but I
believe you're gonna have a
multi-hundred million dollar exit before
the age of like 33 very likely what are
you 28 now 29. you're going to be you're
gonna be worth at least 100 million
dollars in the next five years I would
imagine liquid that's my prediction
but in order to get there I think what
people like we started I talk about
sometime they're like there's this
always like revisionist history of like
oh I had this great idea when in reality
uh like you just do dumbass like kind of
Meathead stuff and you just kind of can
iterate your way and then after like you
get to like some type of sustainability
in some type of Mastery you're like okay
I actually clearly see the path now and
like maybe I'll go back in time and say
I had this like Revelation that we have
to build this big thing you said your
story earlier you're like I thought this
I thought crypto was going to be a big
thing but no one was covering it but in
reality it was like ethereum sounds sick
um I I need a job
um I'm just gonna Host this event and
see what happens like you know what I
mean you just kind of like do [__] and
it works out sometimes there's always
basically a so like that is true what I
said about like we had this Vision that
crypto would be this institutional asset
class because once we said Hey how do
you host an event what what should we
talk about I think our first talk like
one of our first friends was like crypto
and the institutional age of blockchain
or something like we had that Vision
right but yeah I think you are dead
right and I think that is a
almost a problem that gets pushed is
that everybody thinks that Founders had
this vision from day one but if you talk
to Founders who have built big companies
99 of them do not they do they never did
at the beginning second time Founders
actually do I've noticed like second
time Founders will but
um honestly like 100 of first-time
Founders there's no Grand Vision it's
this kind of it's this like how did
blockworks get built I don't know we
took one foot in front of the other day
after day and like slogged it out and
that's how you build your first company
second company I think is different
second company can be like
you know Robotics and like all this
other
[__] but that's
you can have a Grand Vision but not the
first company yeah I don't think it is I
think that um I remember when I started
my first the very first thing I started
I was like
I want to start a newsletter and then I
had this horrible idea I just read the
biography of Ted Turner and he like
employed all these people and I was like
that sounds amazing I want to employ 10
000 people and then I had like a team of
10 and I'm like no I definitely don't
want ten thousand of these [__]
hanging around like this is just too
hard
yeah and like he inspired me but I'm
like oh my God I don't want all these
people and and I just made so many
mistakes but then the second or third
time around you definitely have a more
Clear Vision you also have more um
you have more uh
you have more wisdom and and that shows
up in the sense of like look like after
we do this for like two or three years I
have a feeling we're gonna be able to do
this in like five years like you have a
little bit more Vision but you know it's
still pretty murky but you also have a
lot more patience and Trust in the in
the cycle or in the evolution because
things evolve but when you're first
starting stuff you like you're like this
isn't even gonna work to get to point B
let alone like they get about Point C
and D you know what I mean
a hundred percent I think that's a big
fallacy and I think the other one is um
this idea that it gets easier as you
grow right that's um I think anyone
startups are like this weird or being a
Founder is this weird thing where like
I think what they
you kind of hold constant the rate at
which you can tolerate problems and
everything else kind of becomes this
variable that moves and you're always as
a Founder in this zone of Max Payne and
whenever you are able to if you're ever
below that threshold of Max Payne you
take on more stuff and I think that is
that's something I thought at the
beginning which was like when blockworks
Hits 10 people oh man it'll be a lot
easier all right when blockworks hits
like 30 people a lot easier and that's
um I don't know just listening to
Patrick Collison the founder of stripe
on a podcast
but dude's in Max Payne right now you
think so oh yeah oh yeah he is reading
between the lines of that company it he
is in Max Payne and uh doesn't get any
easier so do you have you read the have
you read the Elon Musk biography I'm
reading right now I'm like 200 pages in
I haven't started it yet but all my
friends keep talking about it and his
life sounds miserable he does it does
not I wouldn't trade I wouldn't trade
what he has for in a million years I
would I it sounds miserable
um like his personal life sounds awful
his professional life sounds awful
everything about it sounds bad it does
not sound enjoyable in the slightest can
I flip the script am I allowed to ask
you a question here so this is a
conversation you guys were talking with
the soil and guy about like what you're
optimizing for basically
um and you guys are like some people
optimize for money right some people are
optimizing for happiness some people are
like he said the things like you you
know every person has a duty to make a
big impact on the world so some people
are I did not agree with him I did not
agree I know you called him out on that
but what are what are you because you're
doing Hampton again you Pro I don't you
probably have enough money where you
could just sit on it and put it in some
like treasuries for the rest of your
life but you're doing Hampton again what
are you optimizing for I'm optimizing
for fulfillment so I'm uh so when I took
time off after selling my first company
I was incredibly lonely I was very I
think I think they're Scott Galloway
talks about like a loneliness uh
epidemic particularly amongst young men
and I I experienced that where I was
like I'm just so low I feel alone I I
feel like uh quite unhappy
um I felt proud of my previous
experience but I felt lonely and so I
started the business because I wanted
um a new challenge where like I just
wanted to achieve something and I wanted
to succeed at something but more so I
wanted to be less lonely and I wanted to
be in the trenches with the troops and
like create something together
um I think that uh young men I imagine
young women but I'm a young man so I
don't know that perspective is that like
I need something to chase after with a
team of of people who I enjoy being near
um and that's really what I was
optimizing for I'm also optimizing for
um
living life on my own terms
um so the reason why I'm not willing to
do like this what John said what did he
say he was like you got to build
something big I'm like dude I don't want
that because I feel like you're signing
up you're signing up to live a life
where you where you have so like there's
like three things there's like what do
you want to do
what should you do and what do you have
to do and I only want to spend my time
doing like the things I have to do and
the things I want to do
I don't want to do things that I should
do so let's just say that you have a
huge company with 10 000 employees you
have to do you should be doing lots of
meetings with them you should be talking
to your investors I don't want to do any
of that there's [__] in my life that I
have to do like no matter what I'm okay
with some of those but I want to
maximize my time for things that I want
to do and so that's kind of what I'm
maximizing my life for is is spending my
time how I want to spend it not things
that I should be doing does that make
sense yeah it does make sense yeah and I
think that when you sign up for those I
think that like Brett Adcock was on the
Pod yesterday or Monday and he's this
guy who goes big the thing about him is
I believe he's happy like he's doing
what he wants to be doing I listened he
sounds like it and I'm happy that freaks
like him exist but I am not that person
I like I don't want to go into the
warehouse or his Factory on a Sunday and
like mess with robots that's just not
how I find fulfillment I would rather
read a book and be by myself on a Sunday
so like I I just don't I don't want to
like sign up to those big uh
world-changing ideas because I feel like
you're obligating yourself to live a
life for other people do you know what I
mean I do not even is that how you feel
kind of I think fulfillment's a good way
to put it but if I had to like distill
that into a couple different things like
well first off there's Safety and
Security in starting your own business
um
I think it is a one one idea that is in
like people's heads in the U.S
especially people who like graduate from
good schools and they go into like the
workforce that has been broken in the
last year which is going to be really
interesting to see how this plays out is
that working at like a big tech company
is a safe thing to do like the number of
people have been laid off from like big
Tech and from Banks and stuff like that
recently is um is incredibly high right
and so I actually think there's more
Safety and Security and doing something
that you own and where you can like
manage 100 of the risk like you can be
the best employee somewhere and if all
hell breaks loose and like the companies
doesn't have a good business model you
can get let go so I think there's Safety
and Security in doing your own thing I
think there's autonomy like just the
type of Personality that I am I've never
done one of those like Myers-Briggs
things but I'm sure it would say I need
my own autonomy like I could I would not
work well in other companies I would say
um
and then I think there's this like
need to
I think building a company is also like
a very personal growth type of thing
um and I think you like you there's no
way block Works can grow if Mike and I
don't become better as humans and I like
that it's this forcing function to
become a better person yeah and I think
in some in a weird sense and I don't
want to like Grand like act like this is
some like big world changing idea or
that like what I'm doing isn't selfish
but
um
it's almost like being an artist you
know I joke about it I'm like dude just
like give Pablo Picasso like a freaking
tuba and he'll make art out of it like
and and that's sometimes how I feel
about when I'm playing on the internet
yeah we were talking about like
different ideas that you were you're
takering with or that you're like
different opportunities that you're
spotting what uh what interests you at
the moment you're not gonna go and start
anything because you have a full-time
gig but is what interests you I mean
though like just crypto right now I'm
like head like just super deep into
crypto I think there are other startup
ideas like if if someone waved a wand
today and said you couldn't go work in
you couldn't go work in crypto
um what would I do I would probably
there's probably two maybe three things
there's only two things I would look at
that I think are huge opportunities
first off you remember when everyone
started creating like the Uber for
X like the Uber for whatever I think
we're about to see that with um with
beehive actually what is that what does
that mean do you have this newsletter
platform that's just like a 10 times
better newsletter platform than anything
on the market I know you are friends
with the convert kit guys so sorry sorry
to him I like Tyler I like convertkit
too or I like uh beehive too I'm also
super biased because I'm an investor in
beehive but like we don't use it yet
because it'll be Enterprise scale soon
but it's more for like the individual
creating their their newsletter all they
did is they just had a
super deep understanding of newsletters
right Tyler was I think CTO of morning
grew before this they just had a super
deep understanding right deep domain
expertise and then they just built a
really slick UI ux and a really deeply
technological like technologically more
powerful platform than anything that
exists on the market and I think you're
going to start to see people basically
say hey beehive was able to do this in
newsletters where there's all these
platforms right campaign monitor send
grids sale through convert kit sub stack
and they just did a 10 built a 10 times
better product I think you're going to
see people try to do this for other
Industries if I were doing it I would do
it for conferences we have used six
different ticketing Platforms in six
different years of block works and it's
always been we like our current one
actually kind of a little bit right now
um but in the past it's just been a
nightmare to find a ticketing platform
and there's this company called hop in
that uh was like one of the hottest
startups of the year a couple years ago
during during covet I heard the founder
took 100 million dollars in secondary
yeah he did he did I actually heard it
was even more than that but he um that's
insane yeah it's insane they raised a
seven billion valuation they just sold
for 15 million so down from 7 billion to
15 million
so it happened sold for you should you
should fact check me on this but I think
for 15 million
no way no way yeah ring central
uh acquires hop-in events and session
products for 15 million holy [__] and
the founder took over 100 million
dollars in secondary uh funding yeah
dude he won that one yeah he did win oh
my God
anyways that's um that's what I would do
so I think hoppin kind of hoppin could
have dominated this Market but they had
this stupid thesis that virtual events
were going to take over physical events
which was like the dumbest thing I've
ever heard and um and and so they failed
but if they had just built a better
product for event hosts and conferences
that was just a 10 times better product
that's a that's a philosophy business
that's a [__] business that's a good
business no I don't think it is I think
that like if you look at Eventbrite look
at their their market cap I I haven't
looked at them forever I'm pretty sure
it's been like slow growth I also think
um are you looking it up let me know I
also think that um there's this company
called Splash do you remember Splash
splashthat.com oh yeah you're right
you're right I remember I think they
rebranded the splash so it was it was
great it was like Eventbrite but they
just made a Slicker landing page for
cheap or free events and it was great it
was really fun I I created so many
events with splash I think splash.com
and I have no idea if they still exist
and the problem with them is that most
of or I I think the problem was is that
most events are like ten dollars or
forty dollars or something like that and
they could only earn like three percent
or two percent or some number like that
of the ticket sales and it seemed like a
really small business that raised tens
of millions of funding that never came
to fruition uh so that's a good that's a
good pushback I would go Enterprise so
the reason I think probably Eventbrite
so the reasons flashlight didn't work is
because they were trying to sell to like
random people just setting up events it
was kind of like a party full if you
know party full now and then like they
were kind of flirting with with yeah so
many people are using that I I don't
think that will work they were kind of
flirting with Enterprise but like
weren't really doing it Eventbrite like
they're probably cost of support alone
is like a total nightmare
um just because they have like anyone
can go create an event on on on uh
you know what you know it's a better
comparison Sam bizibo I would just go
make like a 10 times better bizabo
what's bizibo it's an Enterprise events
platform it's like it's they sell like
SAS it's like 20K a year 30k year
subscription you host all your platform
your events on them they don't take a
cut of the fee of the of the ticket
sales I don't think it's just a but the
platform sucks it's a [__] product
um but they just dominate the Enterprise
event space right now why are you
interested in hair transplants uh the
rate of balding in men right now uh the
hair transplant hair transplant space is
the one of the fastest growing markets
um in in all of medicine right now hold
on I have I was actually researching
this before this
um did you ever get Lasik eye surgery no
I'm afraid to do it I should do it but
I'm afraid so Lasik 20 years ago was
this like kind of sketchy thing to do or
maybe 25 years ago and now it is so the
success rate is 99.9 the costs have come
down 95 for surgery and everybody gets
Lasik it's like a thousand bucks or
something like that but before it was
way more expensive and way riskier and I
think you're about to see the same thing
happen with hair transplants and the
reason I think it's so first off the
market market size five billion dollars
last year projected to reach 30 billion
by 2031 so eight years it's going to go
from a five billion dollar market to a
30 billion dollar market that's a
compound annual growth rate of 20 Euro
year over year
the people that you are selling to are
the most desperate cohort of individuals
right like started losing a little hair
on the back of my head that sucks like
that is a thing that you don't want
right so I think and I think you see
this already with hymns and
the other one I forget Roman or
something whatever the name is like
they're selling like fear of balding
basically and they've been able to
create these huge businesses and I think
if you're able to
do this like if you look at the hair
transplant market today it's a bunch of
just like
kind of like semi-shady plastic surgeons
like billboard like like billboard
having like billboard yeah exactly those
kind of people and like you have to sign
like these waivers where it's like
you know like 50 pages of like I will
not Sue you is what it sounds like and I
just think there's a an opportunity to
build a better to build to build
something like that can you um tell me
how so a a thing that before I started
Hampton I was really interested in the
research business particularly data I
screwed this up with Trends man at the
hustle we had this business called
trends
I charged 300 a year it's really dumb
and I went like fairly broad we should
have just done that before a more narrow
Niche and you're one of the few
companies I think that's gonna a few
Media Company a few media first
companies that's gonna pull off having
a totally non-related income stream to
ads how does their your research
business work because I'm I'm what I've
noticed is that there's very little
Innovation not Innovation but there's
very there's very few younger people
talking about it because it's not very
sexy but if you look at a lot of really
large companies for some reason a lot of
them are in England but there's like a
lot of research businesses that are
making hundreds of millions of dollars a
year and they've been doing that for 50
years but they're so big and the
founders are dead and so like I'll go
and like read the biographies but I'm
like I don't know even know how you
started this damn thing because like
it's been lost in 50 years of History
how is how does your what's your
research business providing the user and
how do you operate it how does it work
basically in crypto there are these
things called protocols like uniswap and
Ave and compound and then there's like
these layer ones like ethereum you've
probably heard of Solana all these other
things the industry is moving from
treating these protocols like they're
these like weird esoteric things to
treating them what like what they are
which is just businesses so maker Dow
for example
they'll do 100 million in Revenue this
year that is a business they have like
people they pay like employees and
contractors profits costs that is nobody
talks about them like that so what block
horse research does is it's a platform
for investors who allocate to crypto
assets to basically look at uh these
crypto protocols and look at their user
metrics financials get research on them
we're very early to Trends with what's
happening with the protocols you can
look at the governance so like if you
want to look at uh who's voting on
different proposals if you want to look
at like how people are how people like
who are the big stakeholders inside the
protocol you can look at all of that
inside the platform so it's probably not
useful to you it's incredibly useful if
you're a crypto fund who Alec who has
like two percent of their portfolio in
in crypto so and and you're getting and
so the way that you built like V1 was
did you just go and find like a dozen or
something public click or private
databases and aggregated all the
information into an easier to use way
and then do you like write articles on
your findings
we started with we started with with
research so what we started with was we
just hired analysts and had them write
like what feels like almost sell side
research on these protocols and we put
it behind a paywall it's super easy we
started with 25 bucks I don't know I
don't know what South Side research
means you're using these words and I
don't know what they mean so I'm going
to interpret it as disrespect
and it is disrespected it's uh
it's like these 10 page research report
you got a lot to learn my friend
I don't know [__] anything dude it's
these like 10 page reports on like how
is something doing so they'll be what's
like
the salsa you know so in in finance
there's no I don't know anything man you
had a family in finance you know this
[__] man my dad sold onions for a living
I love onions so anyways we have there's
there's like deep research basically on
these protocols so instead of a news
story which might be a couple hundred
words there's like a 10 page report like
here's how we think the asset's going to
do here's how that we think the protocol
is going to do here's how the last
quarter the user metrics looked compared
to this quarter that all went behind a
paywall that's how we launched then we
did what you're talking about which is
we basically just started there's all
these inside these protocols they vote
publicly on what to do with the protocol
and it's called like forums and
proposals and that's a total pain in the
ass to track that it all happens in like
Discord and all the and on these
disparate sites we just super manually
scraped all that information put it into
a database then built a front end for
that and put it behind the paywall and
now we've automated most of these
processes but back then it was just a
lot of like very manual uploading and
then um two weeks ago we launched our
analytics product which is like the data
product where you can see the user
metrics and the financials for any of
these protocols so if you want to look
at hey what was ethereum's Revenue
yesterday I can tell you that hey what
was this ethereum's Revenue compared to
Solana's Revenue yesterday I can tell
you that user metrics of like this
exchange versus this exchange I can tell
you all that
how much did the first product cost to
build
uh likes
like a million bucks probably so we have
we have a team of eight analysts and a
couple of Engineers
and how big do you think this business
could get just the research side I think
Politico Pro what were they doing they
were doing like 100 million in Revenue
weren't they
yeah Politico sold for a billion
um so the reason yeah so the reason
politico's business was nice was they
had a huge media business and then about
you know 0.01 of Their audience
converted into the research platform and
that was called Politico Pro so yeah we
think I mean we think it can get much
bigger than that
um we think that there's a lot more ad
dollars and a lot more research like
subscription money in finance than in
politics so like low end of the spectrum
you've got Politico they sold for a
billion Bloomberg terminal is like the
super high end almost like it's like
saying you want to build a Google or an
apple it's like Bloomberg's one of the
best businesses in the history of the
world they'll do like nine billion in
subscription Revenue
um so that's a crazy business but
somewhere in between there's like
refinitive right nobody knows refinitive
there are capital markets information
platform they sold for I think 27
billion uh cap IQ right fact Set uh a
lot of a lot of like multi-billion
dollar companies just built on the back
of basically one asset class like
Bloomberg was just bonds and then you
expand out from there
are you taking all your personal money
Jason's money from the company and
buying crypto right now so Mike and I
don't pay ourselves that much so we
don't I mean most of my money is just in
Block works like if block like it's just
yeah I don't I don't like I don't have
too much money yet
but you're heavy on crypto right person
I mean of what you're of of your liquid
portfolio of my liquid portfolio I'm
until very recently I was 100 in crypto
yeah you're insane man I think that's so
stupid that is insane you and my wife
are you and my wife agree so that's not
the case anymore but uh if it was up to
me I'd be 100 in crypto really still
that's crazy man why I have deep deep
deep conviction on this industry yeah
more conviction than the energy drink
slightly yeah yeah deep deep deep
conviction and like I think it's one of
the best things to work on for the world
uh and I think it's
from an allocation perspective like risk
reward perspective there's no better
industry in the world to work in than
crypto right now I was talking to Sean
the other day like through text I was
like I my my preferred route for
personal finance is just like his
argument is I was like well do you think
that I think the trailing 100 years is
going to repeat itself and he and he
kind of is like well I I actually don't
believe that okay so because I believe
it I think like an 80 20 of stocks and
bonds is the way to go
um but what I think is if you have a
private company like blackworks like I
used to I think it's reasonable to keep
most of your liquid money in a in almost
mostly bonds or t bills or some type of
like liquid but low rate of return but
safe bet and then you have what's it
called a barbell strategy and then you
have the rest of your money in a
high-risk thing being your private
company your private company I would say
it's not crazy high risk because it's a
profitable business with years of
operating history
but if I'm in your position I'm or my my
criticism of of that of that portfolio
is
you have your liquid money and a high
risk bet at the moment
and you also have and you also have your
private money or your your your your the
majority of your net worth and also a a
somewhat high high risk uh thing doesn't
that freak you out I know I know you're
neurotic like I am how do you go to bed
at night like thinking like that don't
no it doesn't freak me out I don't I I
it doesn't freak me out at all and
here's one difference you you have money
right uh nobody ever got wealthy through
diversification no single person ever
got wealthy through diet you are wealthy
it's just not in cash your blackworks Is
wealth it may not be cash money but it
is well it is something I get that and
then you could make the argument that
look if crypto Works block works is a
you know billion multi billiard whatever
you want to call hundreds whatever you
want to say whatever number you want to
assign to it so I'm basically already
betting big on crypto so yeah put it in
put in equities
that's the reasonable thing to do I'm
I'm not
I think you're probably right I just am
uh it's you know what it is it's uh it's
this cheesy Jeff Bezos regret minimum
minimalization thing it's like you know
what would kill me Sam
if I didn't have any of my personal
money in crypto and crypto went the way
I think it's gonna go that would that
would like kill me to my bones you know
what wouldn't really
like it would suck but I would be like
at least I took a bet is
if crypto went down another like 90
percent
wouldn't phase me at all I'd be like you
know what I took a I took a bet and even
though even though I make fun of you I
respect that I I think that I I do
respect it I think you're in a really
good I think you you're no different
than the Brett Adcock who we just had on
of like who's just like you have an idea
you have a vision you have a you think
the world's gonna go one way and you're
talking you're talking the talk and
you're walking the walk and so I I
deeply respect that I think the good
news is is that you're you're such a
wonderful entrepreneur that it's gonna
everything's gonna be great uh in the
grand scheme um but I always like to
push back on people who uh yeah uh are
dude he's also just uh like the way the
world is going so I probably agree with
you about the s p like the s p will most
likely just keep doing what it's doing
and like I say it's a safe place to go
but like does any part of you look at
what's happening
with the world and say like things might
be a little different in the future you
ever do you know who Peter turchin is no
is it wait is he a does he does he spell
his name funny does it actually start
with a t it does it does so all right so
Peter churchen's this historian and
mathematician he developed this field
called Clio Dynamics and he kind of
studies the you would like him he's a
history guy studies like the cycles of
cooperation and conflict amongst Elites
and societies throughout history and his
argument is that periods of internal
peace and cooperation are disrupted when
the population of Elites grows too large
and then competition emerges among them
for what is actually these limited Elite
positions which then because there's too
many Elites and two little positions
that leads to infighting in the elites
as they try to maintain their wealth and
status and it causes social instability
and a breakdown in cooperation and it
doesn't historically that
breakdown cooperation social instability
does not stop until there's a crisis
like
something big right State collapse
Revolution whatever it may be and then a
new new cycle of cooperation resumes so
I don't know if you tend like if you
look at history you can cut you can see
history through the lens of whatever
lens you want to see it there's like the
the fourth turning which is like these
four big periods and you can explain it
like that there's like this Peter Church
in Clio Dynamics view but
one thing I believe is like crypto is a
better way out of this whole system
so let me give you my argument against
that cool I think it could be true and I
don't know anything about this guy but I
want to re I want to learn about what he
has what he thinks I know I read a lot
of history books and that's I do it for
fun
um not for like trying to find the
answer to this question but what I've
noticed is that when Empires cease to be
number one
they don't go to not existing oftentimes
they just go to being like number five
or number seven for example England
so or or let's just like look at I just
pulled it up I just look at what the I
shares Emerging Markets ETF is for the
trailing
30 years it's compounded annual return
is something like five or six percent a
year
so the reason why I'm I'm willing to bet
over the next hundred years that the
trailing hundred years will repeat
itself is because if it doesn't repeat
itself it's not it's still not going to
be that bad it will go from so actually
in the last 15 years I think it's been
you know crazy I think it's been like 13
a year I think that if it's not seven or
eight percent it might be five or six do
you know what I mean yeah I kind of
agree with that it's not going to go
away it will maybe not be as good but
it's not going to go away that's kind of
my point that's what I believe in
I I agree with that I I agree with that
I think I think we're on the same page
but I think that you just I think I
think it's just far more exciting to
read about America ending than it is
about the same [__] happening over and
over again I don't think America yeah I
don't think America is going to end and
I don't think that um this is my problem
with kind of like the bitcoiners which
you're not in like you don't spend time
on crypto Twitter so you're and you're a
lucky man for that but like the way the
best way for Bitcoin to really work is
for the US to collapse and that is a
really shitty vision for the future and
um that's why I like don't align with a
lot of like the the bitcoiners I would
say bitcoin's a good hedge but like I
don't want Bitcoin to go to a million
because the world in which Bitcoin goes
to a million is the world in which like
civil war is back in the US so but but a
theory but ethereum and like what is
happening in in D5 is a very different
vision and that is a vision that like
says look these companies that were
built in the in the in Amazon Facebook
Google and apple they have become far
too powerful the traditional way to uh
or like what the US thinks is the way to
like decrease their powers through
regulation I don't personally believe
that that's the way to do that and I
don't think that will work and I think
that the best way to
to like build a better future there is
through is through crypto so
as we wrap up tell me the the books and
articles that you've read on this topic
who is that guy what was his name Peter
turchan okay and what are the other it
sounds like you've read about this what
else is good fourth turning is good
how long is that book dude I I can't do
read a thousand pages on this topic what
is your current thought on cryptosam
just out of pure curiosity here
and like seeing something like
permissionless with like thousands of
people walking around like do you think
that is a scam do you think it's just
not gonna work do you think are you
excited about it but you don't
understand it like I'd just be very
curious to get your take there I'm not
incredibly well versed so I will preface
anything by saying that like I'm not I'm
not that well versed in it but I would
say that the major things in the space
like Bitcoin and ethereum I I do I I
enjoy the uh I uh like the ideology of
it like I I respect that and so I
support it I think that ninety percent
of the rest of the stuff is a complete
scam I think nfts are for the most part
total [__] I think web 3 for the
most part is total [__] and I think
that the people who entered into that
space oftentimes are horrible
entrepreneurs who are looking for get
rich quick schemes and by slapping uh
web 3 or an nft onto it rather than
building a widget that truly solves a
problem that people love that isn't just
built to sell to other people in that
space
so
um
that's what I believe so I own ethereum
and I own Bitcoin and I like to sit on
it and I enjoy the idea that it could
exist because I I I'm in favor of like
the government not controlling certain
things I think it will exist for a very
long period of time it will potentially
become more useful but most everything
else in the space I think is nonsense
cool interesting cool what do you think
what do you think about that I think uh
I think you're generally right that
there are a lot of like hucksters who
come into crypto and that was probably
true two years ago anyone who's still in
crypto is is not a scam artist um it's
two that no one no one operating in a
market that's 90 down trying to scam
people
um but two years ago generally the same
and I think like you love history you
read all the same history books that I
do like you there are a lot of parallels
to new Industries right whether it's
like all the scammers coming into the
oil industry right in like the 1870s
like very similar because this is get
rich quick money trying into the
railroad industry same thing get rich
quick money into the car uh into the
electricity industry into the car
industry like basically 90 of people who
came into those Industries they were
scammers
um and I think that America because
we're talking super macros like America
is probably the most optimistic country
in the world and that leads to frauds
and you can't have one without the other
so like in places is where they're not
optimistic they don't have frauds they
also don't have companies that get
billed so I think those are like you
can't have best part about someone's
also the worst part about someone say
one in the same I think the worst part
about crypto is that the people who were
selling [__] social media
consultancies or agencies then
crypto I agree
I agree and now they're in AI now
they're in Ai and now they're and now
they're in Ai and I think it's that's
bad for that industry it's like being a
presidential candidate and like the KKK
assuming like being like Oh we love you
you'd be like no no
get the hell out of here you know what I
mean that's like what it's like yeah
it's like we're like get out of here
yeah so I think that's been quite bad uh
for the crypto industry in this in the
same way yeah it is AI now but that
that's kind of my opinion
um I agree what's your plug block Works
research Yano on Twitter what are you
what are you doing yeah yeah and on
Twitter
um we got blockworksresearch.com I have
a podcast we have eight eight crypto
podcasts at block work so if you like
crypto podcast go to you know we've got
a bunch I host one called Empire
that's the plug come to our conferences
Das London coming up March 2024 going
across the pond
well I appreciate you coming on that's
the pod
that's the pod
[Music]
foreign